What specific reason is it that Ramadan
is called the month of forgiveness or is
known as the month of Yes. As I rightly
mentioned earlier that a beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said it's in
a hadith of say bkari volume number
three book of fasting had number 1901
our beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said that if anyone fasts in
the month of
Ramadan with the proper intention with
faith and asking for reward of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala he will forgive all
your past sins and this message is
further repeated in the Muslim
volume number three had number
11524 where it's mentioned that any
person who fasts in the month of
Ramadan with the proper intention
seeking the reward of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala he will have all his previous
sins
atoned and further it's mentioned in Sai
Muslim volume number one had number 450.
Our beloved prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said that the time
between the five
prayers and the two jummas and from one
Ramadan to the other is the time for
expiration of your sins. This is the
time where you can have all your sins
forgiven. And a beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam also said
it's mentioned in Sai Muslim volume
number four in the book of TBA had
number 6644 a beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said that Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala at night time a
person who asks for forgiveness he
forgives the sin for the sin he has
committed in the day and Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala in the daytime he forgives the
sin for a person who ask forgiveness for
the sin He has committed night. So this
is the best month of forgiveness, the
month of Ramadan where you can easily
have your sins forgiven because the
gates of heaven open and the gates of
hell are closed. Therefore, it's called
the month of forgiveness. Allahbar. No
wonder everybody wants to be active in
that month. Now we know why. Subhan
Allah.